اهلا بكم من جديد اعلانات سيئه مكافحه
الفساد في الكويت نزاهه عن تسجيلها واحدا
51 بلاغا تتعلق بشبهات جرائم الفساد خلال
ال 10 اشهر الماضيه وكشفت هيئه مكافحه
الفساد في احصائيه لصحيفه القبس الكويتيه
ان اعلى معدل للبلاغات والرصد الى الاشهر
العشره الماضيه كانت ضد وزاره الاشغال
باجماله خمسه بلاغات تلتها اربعه بلاغات
في كل من وزاره
الكهرباء والصحه
في نسختي الاولى انطلق اليوم في الرياض
ملتقى الحكومه الرقميه بمشاركه جهات
حكوميه السعوديه ونقبه من الخبراء
والمختصين وصناع القرار في مجال الحكومه
الرقميه وجرى خلال الملتقى الرسمي للمنصه
الموحده للحج والعمره
221 خدمه خدمه
من ملتقى الحكومه الرقميه بالرياض ينضم
الينا مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز نوف مرحبا
بك ماذا في هذا الملتقى وهو الاول وفي
نسخته الاولى ايضا
نعم خالد اهلا بك يترجم ملتقى الحكومه
الرقميه في نسخته الاولى التقدم السعودي
العالمي في المجال الرقمي خاصه بعد ان
احتلت السعوديه المرتبه 31 عالميا في مؤشر
الامم المتحده للحكومه الالكترونيه اضافه
الى العديد من الانجازات التي تتم سواء
كانت عالميه او محليه من قبل الجهات
الحكوميه مثل هيئه الحكومه الرقميه وزاره
الاتصالات وتقنيه المعلومات وايضا الهيئه
السعوديه للبيانات والذكاء الاصطناعي همم
المشاركات فاعله في المحافل الدوليه وسعي
دائم للتقدم في المؤشرات الدوليه في هذا
الملتقى الذي يعد التجربه اولى لهيئه
الحكومه الرقميه بعد التقدم في المؤشرات
واطلاق همم القياسات المتعدده ينطلق هذا
المنتدى بمتحدثين دوليين منذ صباح اليوم
حيث ادار الجلسه حواليه همم الدلفينيا
سواريس مديره جامعه الامم المتحده مع
وزيره همم الاتصالات وتكنولوجيا المعلومات
في جمهوريه رواندا تتحدث هذه الجلسه عن
افاق التعاون الرقمي الدولي
والعديد من المحاور الاخرى التي تناقش
مستقبل
الرقمنا وايضا الذكاء الاصطناعي وانترنت
الاشياء العديد من الاطلاقات ايضا تمت في
هذا الملتقى وزراء سعوديين تواجدوا في
الملتقى وزير الحج والعمره الدكتور توفيق
الربيعه كشف عن منصه التي تقدم 160 خدمه
تستهدف الافراد والجهات همم قطاع الاعمال
اضافه الى همم العديد من المحاور المهمه
في هذه المنصه او الخدمات التي تكشف
للمستفيد رحله المعتمر او الحاج وايضا
تمكنه من اختيار باقات الحج والعمره اضافه
الى الكشف عن المواقع التي يمكن لي زائر
همم مكه المكرمه والمدينه المنوره
الاستمتاع بزياره المناطق التاريخيه وايضا
المواقع الاثريه في المشاعر او في مكه
المكرمه والمدينه المنوره بعد او قبل قضاء
النسك الحج او العمره اضافه الى ان وزير
السياحه السعودي احمد الخطيب كشف عن اطلاق
منصه السياحه الموحده التي تتواجد فيها
اكثر من 50 خدمه وهي تاتي حقيقه بعد همم
الانطلاق الاستراتيجيه استراتيجيه السياحه
الرقميه في مؤتمر ليب في فبراير الماضي
والتي تعبت الجميع بالعديد من المنصات هذه
المنصه جاءت واحده من مبادره استراتيجيه
السياحه الرقميه وتمكن المستثمرين
والراغبين بالتعرف اكثر على همم السياحه
في السعوديه من التعرف على المواقع
السياحيه من خلال خريطه تفاعليه توفرها
هذه المنصه التفاعليه والخارطه التفاعليه
وايضا اا تتيح استخراج تصاريح السياحه
بشكل فوري من خلال هذه المنصه حقيقه هذا
الملتقى حقق العديد من الاطلاقات اضافه
الى تواجد رئيس الهيئه السعوديه للبيانات
والذكاء الاصطناعي همم عبد الله شرف
الغامدي الذي كشف عن المزيد من البيانات
واهميه همم تطبيق نفاذ الذي اطلق قبل سته
اشهر وحقق العديد من او ملايين عمليات
الدخول وايضا من الصلاه المستفيده من هذا
التطبيق هذا بشكل عام خالد
مراسل العربيه
مواعيد الاشاره بمذكره زميلنا نواف ايضا
بانه خلال ملتقى الحكومه الرقميه اطلقت
وزاره السياحه منصه الموحده للسياحه بهدف
تقديم تجربه سلسه للاستفاده من الخدمات
الرقميه والبيانات السياحيه حيث ستقدم
منصه خريطه افتراضيه لعرض الفرص
الاستثماريه السياحيه اضافه الى اصدار
التراخيص لخدمات الانشطه السياحيه
[موسيقى]
نيابه العامه السعوديه اليوم اعمال
الاجتماع السنويه الثاني لجمعيه النواب
العموم العرب تحت عنوان قضايا الاحتيال
المالي والامن السيبراني واصلتهما
بالجرائم المنظمه عبر الوطنيه جرى
الاستماع بحضور رؤساء النيابه العامه
وهيئات الادعاء العاملين العرب من عشر دول
العربيه منها السعوديه ومصر والكويت
والاردن بالاضافه الى ممثله عدد من
المنظمات الدوليه والكائنات الاقليميه
ممثله في مكتب منظمه الامم المتحده المعني
بالمخدرات والجريمه ووكاله الاتحاد
الاوروبي
في لقاء خاص مع العربيه قال النائب العام
في السعوديه ان من اهم التحديات الحاليه
والانتشار السريع في استخدام الشبكه
المعلوماتيه في ارتكاب كثير من الصور
الاجراميه التي تمثل جراء الاحتلال تستهدف
الافراد والدول على حد سواء
من اهم التحديات التي كانت سببا لانعقاد
مثل هذه الاجتماعات كما تعلمون هو
الانتشار السريع في استخدامه الشبكه
المعلوماتيه في ارتكاب كثير من الصور
الاجراميه التي تمثل جرائم اغتيال ناسيا
اذا كانت تستهدف ليس فقط الافراد بل
وتستهدف المنظمات الاقتصاديه بما يمسه
الامن الاقتصادي داخل الدول
واكد النائب العام في السعوديه ان من ابرز
مستهدفات اجتماع جمعيه النواب العموم
العرب وايجاد حلول لمكافحه الجرائم
المعلوماتيه ورصد الممارستها والتعاون في
ضبط مرتكبها وفق افضل الممارسات الدوليه
المامون من هذا الاجتماع باذن الله تعالى
هو الخروج برؤيه موحده حيالي وضعي السبل
والحلول لمكافحه تلك الجرائم التي ذكرتها
سابقا
ورصدي ممارساتها
والتعاون في ضبط مرتكبها وفقا افضل
الممارسات الدوليه وعرضي احدث التجارب في
هذا الاطار بما يحققه باذن الله تعالى
الاستقرار الاقتصادي ويساهم ايضا في دفع
عجله التنميه العالميه بين دولنا العربيه
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
اسير تستقبل جهاز المحاكاه لممارسه طيران
الشراعي اداه تعزيز الامان في هذه الرياضه
[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم
ختامه وقمه العشرين في بالي الاندونيسيه
تاكيد على دعم نظام عالمي متعدد الاطراف
ولي العهد السعودي يغادر اندونيسيا متجها
الى كوريا الجنوبيه والترقبون لصفقات بين
الرياض وسهره
ضمن ملتقى الحكومه الرقميه اطلاق كل منصه
الموحد للسياحه في السعوديه
النائب العام في السعوديه يؤكد للعربيه
للعمل على ايجاد حلول لمكافحه الاحتيال
الرقميه
اعربت مجموعه العشرين عن اسافها بشده تجهز
استمرار الحرب في اوكرانيا وذكر البيان
وان معظم الدول الاعضاء اذانت بشداء
العدوان الروسيه على اوكرانيا لكنه هناك
وجوهات نظر اخرى واشار البيان الى ان
التهديد بالسلاح النووي او استخدامها امر
مرفوض تماما واكدت المجموعه استمرار دعمها
للقانون الدولي والنظام متعدد الاطراف
لتحقيق السلام والاستقرار واضاف البيان
وان الحرب في اوكرانيا قودوا الاقتصاد
العالمي وان البنوك المركزيه ستواصل تشديد
السياسه النقديه لكن بشكل مناسب
وبالحديث عن الهجوم الصاروخيه في بولندا
اكد مصدر في حلف النيت وانا الرئيس
الامريكي جوبايدن ابلغ اعضاء الحلف
ومجموعه السبعه الصاروخ الذي سقط في
بولندا اطلقته الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
ومن جهاته اكدت الدفاع الروسيه ان خطام
الصاروخ يشير الى انه اطلق من منظومه
استرات مئه التابعه لاوكرانيا وقالت
الوزاره ان ضربتها كانت في اوكرانيا فقط
واصابت اهدافها بدقه وانها كانت على بعد
35 كم من الحدود الاوكرانيه البولنديه كما
ايدت دفاع البلجيكيه الروايه التي تؤكد ان
الصواريخ اطلقت من انظمه دفاعيه
غادر ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان جزيره اباء للاندونيسيه بعد مشاركته
في قمه العشرين وان الامير محمد بن سلمان
الرئيس الاندونيسي جوكو ودودو بنجاحه
استضافه قمه مجموعه العشرين وكذلك نتائج
الايجابيه التي توصل اليها القاده في
القمه مؤكدا على اهميه مصادر عنها من
قرارات امنا بان تسهم هذه القرارات بشكل
كبير في دعم التعاون بين دول المجموعه
وتعزيز معدلات نمو الاقتصاد العالمي
منبليه تنضم الينا مبتدت العربيه ناديه
البلبيسي ناديه مرحبا بك الى اي حد يرى
المراقبون في بالي ان زعماء وقاده العالم
استطاعوا بالفعل من خلال البيان الختامي
تجاوز الخلافات والانقسامات والوصول الى
توافقات ربما بينهم
اهلا بك يا خالد الانقسامات كانت ربما فقط
بالنسبه للملف الاوكراني والروسي ما تعرف
منذ البدايه الرئيس
الاتحاد الاوروبي الشراك التي اسسها منذ
الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا سواء كانت بضم
اليابان او استرالي او كندا هي معروفه
يعني الموقف الامريكي هو داعم لاوكرانيا
لسياده اوكرانيا هو يرى بان الغزو الروسي
هو انتهاك سافر للقوانين الدوليه وبالتالي
اعلن منذ اليوم الاول عن دعم اوكرانيا
عسكريا واقتصاديا ااه ربما الواضحه جاءت
من هذا المعسكر لكن كما ذكرت هناك همم
اختلاف في وجهه النظر لا نتوقع على الصين
مثلا ان تقوم بادانه روسيا لن اتوقع
لروسيا ان تقوم بازاله نفسها والدول
الاخرى ربما تحاول ان تمارس الحياد نوعا
ما همم ربما ترى الامور من وجهه نظر
مختلفه لكن مسؤول في البيت الابيض قال لي
بانه هذه الدول مجموعه الدول 20 بالاضافه
الى كل دول العالم تقريبا 180 دوله صوتوا
الى ديانه طبعا صالح اوكرانيا في ادانه
الحرب على على اوكرانيا من قبل روسيا في
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده اذا ربما هو
ليس بحاجه الى اذنه لكن ايضا هم تحدثوا
بشكل واضحا اثار هذه الحرب الكارثيه على
الامن الغذائي على الامن الطاقه على هشاشه
الاقتصاد بشكل عام همم واعتقد بان التصعيد
الذي رايناه بغض النظر اذا كان همم
الصاروخين همم كانوا من الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه او لا كما قال الرئيس بايرن
اليوم لكن اعتقد بان تصعيد باطلاق هذا
الكم من الصواريخ هو يعتبر ايضا همم
انتهاك للقوانين الدوليه لانه يهاجم
المدنيين بالدرجه الاولى ومن هنا يعني كان
المفروض اليوم ان يكون يوم سهل بالنسبه
للقاده الخروج بمساوده القرار الاخير وكما
تعرف زرع بعض الشجيرات هنا وهناك للتعبير
عن صداقتهم للبيئه لكن اضطرر رئيس بيدن
الى عقد اجتماع طارق حتى يتعامل همم الحلف
حلف شمال الاطلسي طبعا مع احتمالات ان
تكون بالفعل هذه الهجمات الصاروخيه
الروسيه
ايضا
الاجواء
الابتسامات
والمصافحات الحاره همم يعني التي كانت
تخيم على هذا اللقاء الحديث الودي ايضا
المختصر الذي جمع بينهما
الى اي مدى يمكن القول بانه يبعد البلدين
بالفعل او ان هذه القمه تبعد البلدين
بالفعل عن مسار التصادم وهو ربما الملف
الاكثر اهميه وحساسيه ايضا في ضمن الملفات
المتعلقه بحرب التجاريه بين واشنطن وبكيه
رايناها عليها مشاكل القمه هو الاجتماع
الذي جمع بعد مع شيش بيه رئيس بلده قال
لنا بانه كان يعرف الرئيس الصيني على مدى
سنوات التقاؤه اكثر من 60 مره عندما كان
نائب للرئيس لكن هذه المره الاولى الذي
يلتقي به وجها لوجه قال بانه همم مباشر
كما يعرفه بانه صريح همم ليس حادا ليس
مساوما لكن اعتقد بانه كانت هناك بعض
الانجازات ايضا اولا اللقاء استمر ثلاث
ساعات ونصف هذا يعطينا مؤشر على اهميه هذه
العلاقه همم يعني قطبان يحكمان العالم
اقتصاديا بالذي يحتل المرتبه الاولى هو
الولايات المتحده الذي يحتل المرتبه
الثانيه والصين الصين تريد ان تطيح
بالولايات المتحده على المركز الاول لكن
الرئيس قال بان هذه اريد نسعى الى
المنافسه يعني من حق اي دوله انت تنافس
الدول الاخرى لكننا لا نسعى الى الصراع تم
الى الصين ما من ناحيه بقوله بان الولايات
المتحده متمسكه بسياسه الصين الواحده
بمعنى بنى لا تدعم استقلال تايوان وفي نفس
الوقت لا تريد للصين ان تضمها هناك اتفاق
على حظر استخدام الاسلحه النوويه هناك
اتفاق ايضا على التعامل مع كوريا الشماليه
واسلحته النوويه وربما حتى في الملف
الايراني هناك اتفاق مع الصين لكن هناك
اختلاف في قضايا اخرى عديده على الاقل
طبعا موضوع حقوق الانسان بالنسبه للمسلمين
الويجر وبالنسبه تبات وهون كونج همم
والتنافس التجاري والابقاء على التعرف على
الجمركيه في عهد الرئيس ترامب
والاداره السابقه
في هذه العلاقه بين البلدين يعني همم هل
يمكن القول بان هناك مساحه للتفاهم بين
البلدين امنا الامور مرشحه لتصعيد اكثر
ايضا خلال ساعه
على الاقل المؤشرات التي ااا رايناها في
هذه القمه هي ايجابيه لانه الرئيس ايضا
قال بانه سينفذ وزير الخارجيه الى بكين في
بدايه المطلع القادم السنه القادمه هذا
يعني بانه بالفعل هناك
الابقاء على فتح القنوات اذا اردت واعتقد
باننا قد نبتعدنا عن ما عن التصعيد
العسكري وكما قال مستضيف هذه القمه الرئيس
الامريكي قال بانه لا نريد ان نرى حرب
عالميه همم اخرى وهو يشير الى الصراع بين
روسيا واوكرانيا واثاره التدميريه على
العالم ليس فقط على الدولتين لكن على
العالم بشكل بشكل كبير من ناحيه الامن
الغذائي الطاقه
اكثر من الاقوال وهذا ما يقوله الرئيس
الصيني ايضا شكرا جزيلا لك» مين بقى له
العربيه ناديه البلبيسي
على صعيد اخر على نوالي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان عن تكفل السعوديه
بترميم المركز الاسلامي في العاصمه
الاندونيسيه جاكرتا وذلك بعد تعرض اجزاء
كبيره من المركز لحادث حريق في اكتوبر
الماضي ويضم المركز الاسلامي في العاصمه
الاندونيسيه العديده من المرافق منها مسجد
بمساحه 2200 متر مربع يتسع لاكثر من 20
الف مسلم اضافه الى مركز دراسات بحثيه
وقاعه مؤتمرات
[موسيقى]
تحول وزاره الدفاع لوزير الدفاع الامريكي
تستطيع ان تحافظ على المكتسباتها وتحافظ
على زخامها في المعركه وخلال فصل الشتاء
كما اتطلع للسماء من الوزراء حول
المبادرات الصناعيه خلال مجموعات العمل
وهذه هي الجهود ستساعدنا في توفير وانتاج
وتامين القدرات الدفاعيه لاوكرانيا هذه
الحوارات ستكون مهمه جدا
اثناء دخول اوكرانيا حاليا الى فصل الشتاء
قاسم وبالتالي لا بد من تربيه احتياجاتها
الدفاعي الجويه
وتوفير التدفئه لابنائه واليوم امام
الجدول الاعمال الكبير
واتطلع لاحراز تقدم فيه
الهام منى
بوحده وقوه الشعب الاوكراني
نحن ايضا سنساعد اوكرانيا في
القتال من اجل حريتها وان نعمل على همم
امننا الجماعي نشكركم على التزامكم بهذه
القضيه الان سنتوقف لدقيقه
ويغادر
صحفيين ومن ثم سنصنع من زملائنا الاوكران
حول التطورات في الملف الاوكرانيه التي
تعاهد فيها باستمرار تقديم الدعم الغربي
في هذه الكلمه ايضا الى ان الولايات
المتحده قدم اوكرانيا مساعدات عسكريه حتى
الان باكثر من ثمانيه عشر مليار دولار
يتوجهوا ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان الى كوريا الجنوبيه في زياره
الرسميه هذه هي الزياره الثانيه لولي
العهد السعودي الى سوهاج خلال ثلاث سنوات
ملفات الاقتصاديه الكبرى ستكون على الجدول
للزياره بحضور كوبري شركات الكوريه ورجال
الاعمال وذلك لمناقشه فرص الاستثمار في
السعوديه
من العاصمه الكوريه سول تنضم لننام مفردات
العربيه ميسون ويهض ميسون مرحبا بك
ماذا في تفاصيل جدد هذه الزياره لولي
العهد السعودي الى كوريا الجنوبيه
طبعا سيلتقي ولي العهد مع الرئيس الكوري
الجنوبي ومع رئيس الوزراء سيبحثان طبعا
وسيكون هناك محادثات بين الطرفين حول كل
العلاقات التي تصب في مصلحه البدين
المعروف خالد طبعا انه هذه العلاقات
الكوريه السعوديه ليست والده اليوم بل
انها تمتد الى اكثر من 60 عاما وحتى ان
هذه السنه تصادف ستين عاما مرور ذكرى لهذه
العلاقات التي انشئت والكثير لا يعلم بانه
في السبعينيات وفي الثمانيات الكثير من
العماله الكوريه ساهمت في همم السعوديه في
الاعمال وفي قلبنا التحتيه طبعا هذه
العلاقات هي عميقه جدا وقويه
وبالتالي همم
سمع رؤيه 2030 تحاول السعوديه وكوريا
الجنوبيه ان تلتقي مصالح البلدين مع
بعضهما البعض من اجل نجاح هذه الرؤيا ومن
اجل طبعا مصالح البلدين خالد على هامش هذه
الزياره سيكون هناك منتدى استثماري سيكون
غدا كنا التقينا بالامس سفير همم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في كوريا الجنوبيه السيد
ساميه السدحان واتحدث لنا عن هذا المنتدى
نستمع لكلامه ومن ثم نعود لمتابعه الكلام
معك
سوف يقام ايضا منتدى الاستثمار على هامش
هذه الزياره
[موسيقى]
لجذب الشركات
ورجال الاعمال
في لقاء مباشر مع شركات
ورجال اعمال سعوديين ليتم بحث ومناقشه فرص
الاستثمار في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لذلك هناك حماس كبير من الشركات الكوريه
في الدخول في شركات استراتيجيه واستثماريه
وتجاريه مال القطاع الخاص بالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه
ميسون يعني من المتوقع ايضا على صعيد
انعكاس يعني هذه الزياره على مستوى
العلاقه بين البلدين من ناحيه التجاريه
الاستثماريه وغيرها ايضا في المجلات
الاخرى
في هذه النقطه بالذات خالد نود ان نذكر
بان هناك لجنه مشتركه كوريه سعوديه انشئت
طبعا بعد رؤيه 20 30 هذه اللجنه هي تتابع
كل المشاريع بين البلدين لتسهيل العمل
بينهما حتى تصل الى النتيجه المرجوعه ايضا
ولي العهد سا- يلتقي مدراء كبريات الشركات
في كوريا الجنوبيه خلال زيارته الى كوريا
الجنوبيه
وبالتالي العديد من الاتفاقيات والعديد من
الشركات ستكون همم طبعا ست تاخذ منحا همم
اكثر جديه وايضا سيوقع الكثير من
الاتفاقيات والشركات ومن المعلوم ايضا
خالد هناك شركات سعوديه كبيره ايضا
استثمرت في كوريا الجنوبيه مثلا ارامكو
استثمرت في مصفاه اس اويل هي ثالث اكبر
مصفاه في كوريا الجنوبيه بنسبه اكثر من
63.4% هناك ايضا شركه همم هيونداي اويل
بانك هي مصفاه ايضا متكامله للتكرير بطاقه
معالجه تصل الى
650,000 برميل في اليوم ايضا عام 2019
كانت ارامكو اعلنت بانها استكملت هذه
الصفقه واستحواذها على 17% من هذه الشركه
الكثير من الشركات السعوديه استثمرت في
السعوديه وايضا بالنسبه للسعوديه هناك
الكثير من المستثمرين وما تحاوله ايضا
السعوديه ان تجذب هؤلاء المستثمرين لكي
يكون لهم ايضا فروع في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وخاصه بانه فمعلومه ان المشاريع
الكبيره في السعوديه تجذب الكثير من الدول
والشركات وتحمصهم حقيقه للاستثمار فيها
الزياره بكل تفاصيله لتاكيد سنكون معك
ايضا للمتابعه في نشرتنا لاحقه شكرا جزيلا
لك مفاده العربيه
من العاصمه الكوريه
[موسيقى]
ورابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
مكافحه الفساد في الكويت مستمره واحد
وخمسون بلازا تتعلق بشبهات الفساد خلال 10
اشهر
الى كوريا الجنوبيه والترقب لصفقات بين
الرياض
ضمن ملتقى الحكومه رقميه يتنقل منصه
الموحده للسياحه في السعوديه
في تصريحات للعربيه النائب العام في
السعوديه يؤكد العمل على ايجاد حلول
لمكافحه الاحتلال الرقميه
اهلا بكم اليوم
الحدث الاضخم في مجال الامن السيبراني
2022 عبد الواحد الحميد
يلتقي هنا الاف المهتمين بالامن السبراني
من مختلف دول العالم حيث انطلقت فعاليات
بلاكات الحدث السبراني الاكبر في المنطقه
والتي تجمع افضل العقول واكبر الشركات في
هذا القطاع
الامن السيبراني وما يخدم قطاع تقنيه
المعلومات ايضا لا ننسى ان هو حدث عمره 25
سنه ويعتبر سبق غير مسبوق موجوده في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ويعتبر همم منجم
كبير للمختصين والخبراء لللقاء والمشاهده
اهم الخبرات والقدرات العالميه المتاحه
حاليا في بلاكات طلاب الجامعه والموظفون
واصحاب المشاريع الناشئه وغيرهم يرون في
هذا الحدث الضخم فرصه لاكتساب مهارات
جديده والتعرف على اضخم الشركات في العالم
في مشروع نيوم همم جزء لا يتجزا من خطه
اللي شغالين عليها في المشروع همم
[موسيقى]
دائما نقول انه خط الدفاع الاول في اي
منظمه واي مشروع هو راس المال البشري
فموظفين يوم همم والعاملين في نيوم
والمستثمرين في نيوم هم نواه الدفاع الاول
عن اي تهديد استفرانيه قد تواجه المشروع
بشكل او باخر 23 دوره تدريبيه متخصصه في
الامن السبراني يقدمها 50 مدربا بالاضافه
الى العديد من الاقسام المتنوعه لاثراء
تجربه الزوار
من الرياض عبد الواحد الحميد العربيه
تستعد المواقع التراثيه في الاحساس شرقيه
السعوديه لاستقبال المشجعين بطوله كاس
العالم قطر 2022
قبيلا انطلاقها مطلع الاسبوع المقبل وذلك
من خلال تهيئه الاماكن السياحيه بما فيها
معرض كنت هنا الذي يوثق زياره رحاله
الالمانيه الى الاحساء عام
1904 بتنظيم من جمعيه الاثار والتراث في
المنطقه الشرقيه
يعرفنا اكثر من الاحساء مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي عبد الرحمن
اضاءه منك على هذا الموقع
الاثري الذي يستعيد الاستقبال الزوار
هلا بك خالد طبعا اول شيء يحملك سلام حار
جدا من اهل الحساء يقولون لازم خالد زورنا
في اقرب وقت يعني يحبونك كثير صراحه كل ما
ازور مكان هنا في الحساء الا لما يجيبوا
طارق
هذا الموقع تاريخي والاثري
ههه تسلم يا خالد ففعلا هذه المحافظه
الجميله الوادعه الساحره بمواقعها
التاريخيه والتراثيه تستعد لاستقبال
الالاف من المشجعين سادع الصوره تتكلم
اكثر خالد ودع زميل المصور ياخذ بعض
اللقطات في هذا المكان السياحي الرائع
الذي تم اعاده ترميمه وتجهيزه قبل سنوات
قليله لاستقبال العديد من السياح والزوار
طبعا همم بالخلف ومع مدخل جبل القاره هناك
معرض كنت هنا للرحاله الالماني همم هرمن
بورخارت هذا الحاله الذي زار الاحساء قبل
تقريبا 110 سنوات وثقها ببعض الصور هناك
معرض الصور
لتعريف المشجعين والزوار بتاريخ هذه
المنطقه من بناء العقير وصولا الى الهفوف
القديمه هذا الجبل يشاهده خالد جبل القاره
الميزه في حقيقه انه عندما تقترب من
الكهوف الخاصه بهذا الجبل درجه الحراره
بارده للغايه فهي تعطيك الجو البارد صيفا
والجو الدافئ شتاء هناك اكثر من كهف في
هذه الجبال الجميله في الاحساء هناك ايضا
خطط حكوميه
ورسميه في ما يتعلق باستقبال المشجعين
يعني قبل يومين تقريبا كان هناك اجتماع في
امانه الاحساء بامين الاحساء وايضا الى
جانب وزاره الشؤون البلديه والقرويه وايضا
وزاره السياحه لاستقبال او لعرض الخطط
المستقبليه لاستقبال المشجعين فيما يتعلق
بالخطط الامنيه والصحيه وايضا همم
الخدميه اللوجستيه ايضا قسريه الاحساء
خالد كان هناك ازمه في ما يتعلق بالمواقف
اعلنت الامانه يوم امس انها ستقوم بتوسعه
المواقف
لاستعاب 2700 سياره في مواقف همم سوق طريه
والهفوف القديمه ايضا همم هناك في في هذا
الموقع لان حدثكم من جبل القاره هناك خطه
ايضا من المحافظه لاثراء تجربه السائح
الذي ياتي الى هذا المكان للتعريف اكثر
فاكثر
بتاريخ هذه المحافظه قبل قليل حقيقه خالد
لاحظت بعض الاجانب بداوا بالتدفق الى
الاحساء همم
لمشاهده الاثار وايضا مشاهده المواقع
التاريخيه والتراثيه همم ربما في الايام
المقبله خاصه مع انطلاق كاس العالم همم
مطلع الاسبوع المقبل سنشاهد همم الاف من
المشجعين الذين فضلوا الاقامه في الاحساء
طبعا هناك ايضا خطه من قبل وزاره السياحه
فيما يتعلق بالفنادق والشقق المفروشه
وايضا التاكد من جهزيتها على اكمل وجه
طبعا بالتنسيق مع الجهاز الحكوميه خالد
لكن الملاحظ بان اغلب المشجعين سيؤتون الى
الاحساء
ده همم دور المجموعات او مع بدايه
المباريات في قطر سياتون خاصه ما بين
المباريات بين كل مباراه واخرى يكون هناك
ثلاثه الى اربعه ايام فيما يتعلق
بالمنتخبات فربما يستغلون هذه المساحه من
الوقت لزياره همم
يعطيك العافيه
بشكل عام اللي همم بالتاكيد هناك
استعدادات كبيره للاستقبال يعني المشجعين
كاس العالم بس في ارقام متوقعه عن عدد
المشجعين اللي ممكن يزوروا مثل هذه
المناطق في الحساء او الحسد بشكل عام
الارقام خالد حتى شيئا فشيئا مع بدايه كاس
العالم لا تنسى خالد بان هناك منفذ سلوى
الحدودي الذي سيستقبل العديد من المشجعين
عبر السيارات وايضا هناك المنافذ الجويه
اي شخص يحمل بطاقه هيئه فيستطيع الدخول
الى السعوديه مجانا بدون اي همم تاشيره
فقط عليه تسجيل في الموقع الالكتروني
الخاص
بالحصول على الفيزا السعوديه والاستمتاع
بالمواقع في السعوديه كلها وايضا في منفذ
سلوى هناك ايضا وفي المطارات يعني هيئه
السياحه
وضعت همم مواقع خاصه للتعريف بوجهات
السعوديه السياحيه فاعتقد مع بدايه همم
مع بدايه الانطلاق المباريات خالد ستتضح
الصوره شيئا فشيئا ويتم همم يعني التاكد
رسميا من الاعداد المشجعين الذين دخلوا
الى السعوديه عبر المنافذ الجويه والبريه
لكن
عن منفلوه سيكون هو له نصيب الاسد من
الزوار لاسيما الذين ياتون عبر الباصات او
السيارات
واحنا راح نكون معك بالتاكيد اولا شكرا لك
من الحسد مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن
العصيمي
اعلن الاتحاد السعودي للطيران الشراعي
شاهين عن وصول جهاز المحاكاه للطيران
الشراعي بهدف رفع المستوى
التدريب على رياضه الطيران الشراعيه محمد
خالد
سهم اتخاذ والاتحاد السعودي للطيران
الشراعي شاهين منطقه عسير مقر له في تعزيز
ممارسه تلك الرياضه في المنطقه كونها
مغامره تتناسب مع تضاريس المنطقه واجواءها
المعتدله
عندنا اليوم الجهاز المحاكاه طبعا نفتخر
انه الاتحاد السعودي هو اول اتحاد في
العالم يقتني هذا الجهاز المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تعتبر رابع دوله تقتني هذا
الجهاز هذا الجهاز المحاكي اا يعني ثم
خصيصا للتدريب طبعا في محاكيات ثانيه
للغرب تجربه الطيران لكن هذا المحاكي
الخاصيه اللي فيه انه مختص بتدريب
الطيارين يعني ينقلوا من ليفل الى ليفل
الثاني يعلم المهارات جديده
والممارس حتى للطياره متقدم
[موسيقى]
استضافه الاتحاد السعودي شاهين جهاز
المحاكاه الطيران الشراعيه كاول اتحاد في
العالم يقدم تلك التجربه كما تعد السعوديه
هو لدوله تقتل الجهاز على مستوى الشرق
الاوسط الرابعه عالميا احنا طبعا قررنا ان
نقتني الجهاز في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لعده اسباب اول حاجه للتدريب المنتخب
تدريب الطيارين صقل مهاراتهم وفي نفس
الوقت نشر روايه الطيران الشراعي بين
افراد المجتمع بالخصوص بالمدارس طبعا احنا
عندنا برنامج بتعاون مع اداره التعليم
اداره التعليم منطقه عسير انه بيكون عندنا
متدربين اطفال من من سن تسعه الى سن 18
يشاهد محاكي الطيران الشراعي في تدريب
الممارسين والهوى بطرق مبتكره تحاكي مختلف
حالات الطقس التي يمكن ان يواجهها ممارسها
هذه الرياضه كما يساعد في تعزيز الامن
والسلامه ورفع الوعيه الممارسين من مدينه
ابها محمد خالد
العربيه
الملكيه في مدينه الجزائر للصناعات
الاساسيه والتحويليه عن ابرامها عددا من
الاتفاقيات الاستثماريه بقيمه ماليه
تتجاوز مليار ريال سعودي تضمنت ثلاث
اتفاقيات الموقعه مع عدد من الشركات
بمختلف القطاعات انشاء عدد من المصانع في
قطاعات تشمل الغذاء والحبوب بالاضافه الى
تطوير البناء التحتيه لمدينه جازان
والصناعات الاساسيه والتحويليه
وفي جده تستمر فعاليات النسخه الثانيه من
الملتقى البحري السعودي الدولي بتنظيم
القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه
وبمشاركه اكثر من 37 من قاده ورؤساء
الجهات المعنيه بالبيئه البحريه اضافه الى
مختصين وخبراء عسكريين واكاديميين من داخل
وخارج السعوديه
قسم العلماء النجوم الى قسمين نجوم
استدلاليه ونجوم ارشاديه تفاصيل مع خالد
ازعاج في تقويم
[موسيقى]
تنقسم النجوم الى قسمين نجوم استدلاليه
وهي النجوم التي نستدل بها على الجهات
وعلى الفصول والمواسم ونجوم ارشاديه وهي
النجوم التي ترشدنا الى النجوم
الاستدلاليه وعلامات وبالنجمهم يهتدون
فالهدايه هنا هدايه مشاهده وهدايه معنويه
عقائديه فالنجوم هي القنطره التي توصلنا
الى الله سبحانه وتعالى ولينظروا ماذا في
السماوات والارض وما تغني الايات والنذر
عن قوم لا يؤمنون فالارض وما تحتويه من
جبال ومخلوقات والسماء من نجوم
ومجرات دليل
على عظمه الله سبحانه وتعالى فلا ينظرون
الى الابل كيف خلقت والى السماء كيف رفعت
والى الجبال كيف نصبت والى الارض كيف
سطحات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والنجمه القطبي الذي يسميها العامه بالجدي
يدلنا على الشمال وهو النجم الاوحد الذي
لا يغير مكانه ليش لانه يقع فوق محور
دوران الارض حول نفسها وبنات نعش المسماه
بسبع يرشد اننا عليه وسهيل يدلنا على
الجنوب وين نجم سهيل يا نجم الجدي
ترقى علامتنا الغمام ما علينا طحت من عين
الردي طيحتي من عينه
ارفع للمقام
[موسيقى]
اطلقت ناس صاروخ النحو القمر لاول مره منذ
عقود تحت اسم مهمه ارتميس واحد من ولايه
فلوريدا لتستمر حوالي 25 يوم الهدف منها
الى القمر
3 2 1
ختام الرابعه بالعناوين
ختام وقمه العشرين في بالي الاندونيسيه
تاكيد على دعم نظام عالمي متعدد الاطراف
ولي العهد السعودي يغادر اندونيسيا متجران
الى كوريا الجنوبيه وترقبون لصفقات بين
الرياض
وضمن ملتقى الحكومه الرقميه يطلق منصه
الموحده للسياحه في السعوديه
وفي تصريحات العربيه النائب العام في
السعوديه يؤكد العمل على ايجاد حلول
لمكافحه الاحتلال الرقميه
شكرا للمتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]